Woods slat baskets are made out of
American sweet gum trees first the
freshly cut logs are sprayed with water
so they don't dry out and Decay one at a
time spiked rollers grab the logs and
turn them as knives shave off all the
bark the debarked log rolls down a
conveyor to be cut to the specified
length the wood spins on a the lathe as
a blade cuts into the wood producing
long thin sheets
[Music]
technicians pull the sheets forward and
stack
them the sheets move through rollers the
rollers feed the stack to a long
Guillotine type blade which chops them
into
slats once all of the slats have been
cut the slats are stacked and checked
for quality